lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en cómo puede cambiar el costo de
oportunidad
conforme pasamos de un escenario a otro
veremos en particular este ejemplo pero
es un fenómeno que es común para muchos
escenarios económicos
digamos que comenzamos en el escenario
efe somos vegetarianos y solo consumimos
bayas y no perdemos ningún tiempo
atrapando conejos pero ahora como que se
nos empieza a antojar la proteína y cuál
será el costo de oportunidad si quiero
conseguir ese conejo extra si voy por
ese conejo extra que va a pasar tengo
que quedarme mi frontera de
posibilidades de producción y me voy a
pasar al escenario es así que voy a ir
de cero conejos a un conejo y para eso
voy a tener que dejar de cosechar 20
bayas
así que mi costo de oportunidad para
pasar del escenario efe el escenario en
y conseguir un conejo va a ser de 20
bayas continuamos si estoy en el
escenario y ya estoy consumiendo un
conejo diario y ahora quiero conseguir
dos conejos al día qué implica esto
bueno ahora voy a tener que dejar de
conseguir 40 bayas esto está interesante
ahora digamos que estoy en el escenario
de ya tengo dos conejos diarios y quiero
otro conejo más quiero tres estoy
comenzando a convertirme en carnívoro
pues eso implica que ahora voy a tener
que dejar de conseguir 60 vallas si yo
en promedio puedo conseguir tres conejos
diarios entonces solo podrá cosechar 180
bayas continuamos ahora que quiero otro
conejo más pues tendré que renunciar a
80 vallas
y finalmente me vuelvo por completo
carnívoro y si quiero tener un promedio
de 5 conejos diarios pues tendré que
dejar 100 vallas y ya no podré comer
ninguna valla ese día así que ustedes
pueden observar algo interesante aquí
mientras más conejos quiera yo conseguir
cada vez que voy por un conejo
incremental tengo que dejar más y más
vallas así que se aumenta mi coso de
oportunidad así que este fenómeno y
bueno no siempre es el caso aunque es el
caso en este ejemplo aumenta el costo de
oportunidad aumento del costo de
oportunidad
aumento del costo de oportunidad y esto
va a suceder conforme vayamos aumentando
la cantidad de conejos podemos hacerlo
de la otra manera podemos decir bueno
mientras incrementamos el número de
bayas de manera unitaria aunque no lo
podemos visualizar muy bien aquí como
están los números expresados si fuéramos
aumentando de 100 bayas en 100 vallas
vamos a tener que estar renunciando cada
vez a más y más conejos y aquí lo
interesante es que bueno ya establecimos
estos números pero porque tiene sentido
esto como es que se observa el aumento
del costo de oportunidad en diferentes
fenómenos económicos bueno en este caso
simplificamos nuestra realidad económica
a nuestro modelo económico para reducir
las opciones que tenemos que hacer a dos
variables conejos y bayas pero porque
esto aparece en los modelos económicos
aunque aclaremos que no aparecen todos
los modelos para pensar esto con nuestro
ejemplo comenzamos aquí en el escenario
efe en ese escenario decidimos no
perseguir a ningún conejo ni siquiera
aquellos conejos que son los más lentos
a lo mejor les gusta estar cerca de uno
y estar jugando con nuestras lanzas y
flechas no estamos intentando cazar ni
siquiera esos conejos en cambio queremos
pasar todo nuestro tiempo cosechando
bayas y no estamos hablando de las bayas
que están al alcance de la mano
estamos buscando aquellas bayas que se
encuentran más adentro del arbusto en
donde tenemos que sufrir lastimadas de
espinas o tenemos que estar trepando en
lugares muy incómodos para alcanzar esas
vallas así que nos dedicamos a conseguir
aquellas bayas que son bien difíciles y
no estamos viendo por ningún conejo pero
de pronto si decimos bueno pues este
conejito que está aquí dando lata
alrededor mío y que la verdad como que
está pidiendo problemas pues lo voy a
atrapar porque es muy fácil atraparlo y
no voy a perder tiempo en perseguirlo
pues no voy a tener que dejar de buscar
muchas vallas para atrapar esos
conejitos lentos y en cambio ese tiempo
que me tardo en atrapar a estos
conejitos pues es el que me lleva a
alcanzar esas vallas que son bien
difíciles de conseguir
si yo quiero conseguir dos conejos
diarios pues no solo voy a tener que
atrapar a aquellos conejitos que son muy
lentos y fáciles de atrapar ahora voy a
tener que ir por aquellos conejos que
son un poco más rápidos y por esto pues
no solo estoy renunciando a aquellas
bayas que son difíciles de alcanzar
estoy renunciando también a bayas que
están un poquito más cercanas a mí ya
que me va a llevar más tiempo atrapar a
estos dos conejos de lo que me daba para
conseguir las bayas y este fenómeno va a
ocurrir en todos estos escenarios hasta
el escenario en el que quiero conseguir
cinco conejos diarios y literalmente
tengo que atrapar a aquellos conejos que
son los más rápidos y los más
inteligentes y por estar insistiendo en
atraparlos estoy renunciando a tomar las
bayas que están totalmente a mi alcance
incluso estoy pisando bayas que ignoro
por tratar de atrapar a estos conejos
difíciles así que espero que con esto
ustedes se tengan un entendimiento mejor
de lo que significa el aumento del costo
de oportunidad y si lo mostramos de
manera gráfica en términos de la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
se verá
en estas curvas que tienen una forma
como de arco y lo podemos ver que cuando
vamos de este punto a este punto
conforme aumentamos un conejo la
pendiente negativa de esta curva va
aumentando por ejemplo en el escenario
efe la pendiente es más o menos así y
los invito a que vean la lista de vídeos
de álgebra si es que no saben a qué me
refiero cuando digo la pendiente
negativa pero la pendiente de f es así
esa es la línea de la tangente a esta
curva en el punto de la pendiente es
mayor estamos renunciando a más vallas
por un conejo extra lo mismo ocurre en
de la pendiente es aún mayor en ce
también y en cualquier lugar que veamos
una curva con forma de arco una curva
que luce así sabemos que tenemos un
aumento del costo de oportunidad
conforme aumentamos en unidades tenemos
que renunciar a más y más de la
alternativa